à la question gay à montréal vincent
marissal à montréal et sébastien
beauvais à québec messieurs bonsoir
bonsoir
sébastien expliquez nous le contexte
parce qu'on va on va parler de cette
dernière sortie facebook de pierre karl
péladeau au sujet de cet institut pour
la souveraineté
on expliquait hier sébastien qu'il
voulait poursuivre peut-être la cac et
libéraux parce que eux ont dit que son
éventuel financement de cet institut
serait illégale oui oui ça il
il laisse entendre qu'on le dit femme
qu'on fait de la diffamation que on
attaque son intégrité son éthique parce
que la caq a laissé entendre notamment
qu'il pourrait faire du financement
illégal s'il financer lui-même
institutions la souveraineté jean marc
fournier a dit que parce que monsieur
péladeau avait mis en demeure la
coalition avenir québec de se rétracter
il faisait de l'intimidation politique
alors monsieur péladeau évalue la
possibilité de poursuivre aussi jean
marc fournier aujourd'hui sur une sortie
dans une sortie facebook
il s'en prend aux chroniqueurs de la
presse notamment de nos panélistes ce
soir en parlant de petits soldats de
power corporation de la famille
desmarais et il affirme que ses
chroniqueurs ne dénonce pas par ailleurs
les liens entre la famille démarrer le
pouvoir politique sait pas si on est
réussi à faire la citation on va lire
ensemble incitations sébastien alors la
voyez vous oui ils ont alors il écrit
honte ils le courage de dénoncer leurs
patrons la famille des marais qui invite
à la dizaine des politiciennes on peut
me laisse
charest durant quelques jours à sa gare
mais probablement qu'en vertu de leurs
critères cette information ne serait pas
pertinente
c'est politicienne se sont sans doute
rencontrer pour parler des recherches
sur la copulation des coléoptères au
zimbabwe parce que ce matin à la fois
vincent marissal épaules journée dans la
presse critique un peu si on veut la
démarche de monsieur péladeau dans ce
dossier de l'institut sur la tumeur
était et des menaces de poursuite qu'il
a brandi au cours des derniers jours
vous l'avez dit c'est un hasard mais
vincent marissal est avec nous vincent
bonsoir bonsoir vous avez fait donc une
chronique il hier on a parlé à ce panel
aussi un certain nombre de chroniqueurs
ont dit que si l'institut émanait du
chef du parti québécois
ça devenait plus problématique pour le
financer
qu'est ce que vous répondez aux gros 1,6
attaque de pierre karl péladeau comprend
des patrice que dans ma position
d'autant que je suis cité dans ce texte
c'est d'identifier comme un des petits
soldats de power corp je vais m'abstenir
de tomber dans
dans la personnalisation ce que
malheureusement fait très souvent le
chef du parti québécois monsieur
péladeau repreneur d'ailleurs assez
souvent les mêmes termes les plus
détestables qu'on retrouve sur twitter
et ailleurs époque il n'y a pas que moi
et que mes collègues qui passent
d'ailleurs il le traiter monsieur jean
mach fournit le leader en chambre des
libéraux ya surtout auteur de pelle
toqué de vesle et des termes aussi
généralement des épithètes extrêmement
grossière qu'on retrouve dans des
échanges avec des gens tout aussi grossi
sur tout et on comprendrait que je
répondrai pas aux attaques de monsieur
péladeau ma chronique lé public pouvait
vous pouvez aller lire je travaille pas
pour un petit journal en deux grands
noms se trouvent facilement
j'aimerais ça par contre que monsieur
péladeau au lieu de nous attaquer
personnellement puis de s'en prendre à
mon patron dans une incohérence à sega
c'est complet réponse sur le fond est ce
qu'ils voient ou non lui un problème à
ce qu'il peut-être on ne sait pas encore
parce qu'on connaît pas le détail
finance lui-même un institut qui
directement liées comme un vase
communiquant à son parti parce que c'est
inusité c'est inédit
et c'est ça qu'on dit dans nos
chroniques en tout cas de parler pour
moi c'est ça que j'ai dit dans ma
famille que je pose des questions
là-dessus
est-ce qu'il ya effectivement oui ou non
un problème sur le fond parce que la
question gay on en parlait hier à ce
panel de la différence entre certains
groupes fédéraliste proches
on a un proche parti libéral du canada
un peut-être plus proches du parti
libéral du québec donc dréville posé la
question et hier soir pourquoi c'est bon
pour les fédéralistes et les
souverainistes ne pourrait pas se créer
un institut et hier ce que des analystes
à ayman pas directement des partis qu'en
pensez vous à l'aise à la base pour se
rappeler à quoi sert la loi électorale
et l'oncle plafonnement des
contributions politiques c'est de ne pas
avoir une influence indue de l'argent
sur les débats politiques on le voit aux
états unis à quel point ça peut être
toxique parfois donc au québec et au
canada on n'a légiféré pour être capable
de contrôler un peu qui donne donc des
plafonds évidemment s'il s'est créé dans
les dernières années c'est assez récent
2 sur l'échelle historique le cétacé
récent qui s'est créé des techniques
donc des organismes de réflexion à
tahoua et ici au québec qui sont près
des partis politiques d'une manière
logique donc on réfléchit par exemple au
fédéralisme et la souveraineté à la
gauche à la droite
evènement on tente d'influencer les
partis politiques mais ce n'est pas
arrivé encore qu'un chef créé de toutes
pièces un organisme pour alimenter ce
débat lorsqu on se demande c'est si on
est plafonnée comme souverainiste quand
on donne au parti québécois est ce qu'on
pourrait donc donner des milliers voire
des centaines de milliers de dollars à
un institut qui elle va alimenter la
plateforme électorale du parti québécois
dont on voit par la bande face qui est
interdite directement ça vaut aussi pour
les partis fédéralistes mais c'est vrai
qu'on peut se poser des questions sur la
structure de ces partis deux des six
organismes l'os qui sont structurés
correctement ce que le dge devrait se
poser des questions puisque ça prolifère
dans les dernières années mais c'est
légitime de se poser les questions c'est
un débat politique ce n'est pas un débat
de mise en demeure au juridique c'est
dans l'arène politique en iran de se
poser des questions sur ces organismes
là je trouve ça sain qui est des
molosses sources - 5 on s'envoie des
mises en demeure par la tête parce qu'on
n'aime pas ce qui se dit par exemple et
vincent le disaient ses propos là
aujourd'hui
sébastien à québec qu'est ce que vous
pensez de ce tombeau l'ajustement six
attaques là de monsieur péladeau
aujourd'hui on se demande quand on lit
pierre karl péladeau sur facebook ce
soir qui parle est ce que c'est le chef
du parti québécois ou est-ce que c'est
l'actionnaire majoritaire de quebecor et
quand on se pose cette question là dans
la confusion des genres
monsieur péladeau joue sur le terrain
sur lequel ses adversaires politiques
veulent qu'il joue c'est à dire
d'alimenter cette confusion entre
l'actionnaire majoritaire est le chef du
parti québécois et vous allez vous dire
vous demandé mais où sont les gens des
communications du parti québécois
comment ça se fait qu'on le laisse
écrire de telles choses sur facebook des
attaques directes contre un compétiteur
en termes de d'affaires mais aussi
d'aider des gens qui remettent en qui
est ce qui pose des questions sur sa
démarche mais ils sont pas là des gens
des communications parce que monsieur
péladeau il est probablement un aéroport
charles de gaulle ce soir en retour vers
le québec parce qu'il assistait à des
funérailles en france aujourd'hui et ça
laisse l'impression que des gens des
communications sont pas capables de le
l'encadré dire ça comme ça lorsqu'il
fait une descente
bompas est parce qu on le sait et puis
je vais finir là-dessus et vincent est
un écrin finement que d'autres sujets là
on le sait par compression parce
péladeau c'est un adversaire et souvent
c'est arrivé plusieurs fois depuis
plusieurs années
il s'en prend à cette meilleure cette
main de l'ombre de par compression qui
selon c'est cette thèse alimente la
teinte fédéralisme au québec et même
dans sa lentille dit aujourd'hui la
presse est déficitaire et elle par
compression se paie des journaux pour
promouvoir le fédéralisme et c'est ça
qui ressent tout le temps de qu'il est
chaud qu'il a allait oui et puis quelque
chose d'un peu particulier dans cette
logique là c'est à dire que si tous les
journalistes de marca prochain et donc
de la presse sont à la solde de don de
leurs propriétaires le chp a pas de
ligne éditoriale qui reflète évidemment
la position des propriétaires par des
journalistes qui font leur travail avec
un code de déontologie qui encadrent le
travail soit dit en passant si eux sont
à la solde de power corporation
qu'est ce qui empêche les adversaires de
pierre karl péladeau donc les
fédéralistes de dire donc tous les
employés de quebecor sont des petits
soldats depuis à karl péladeau puisque
lui dirige ou du moins est actionnaire
de contrôle de quebecor alors moi j'ai
toujours pensé que les journalistes de
quebecor faisait le travail le plus
professionnel possible en vertu du code
de déontologie qui vend comme ceux de la
presse aussi mais lui-même alimentent
les inquiétudes que certains ont par
rapport aux médias suis pas certain que
ces 5 à la fin pas très chaude et à
nîmes on est loin du débat sur
l'essentiel sur le fond le samedi la
création de cet institut
l'ale avec toutes les mises en demeure
aujourd'hui facebook on s'éloigne
complètement du débat qui est pas une
mauvaise idée peut-être que de vouloir
obtenir le statut de bienfaisance
je trouve que ça se défend mais qu'il
défende seul chef du parti québécois
mais sans que ce serait plus utile et
pour lui et pour son parti et sur
l'arène politique et d'en faire don dans
la rue nous serions effectivement dans
l'arène politique plutôt que dans le
trou de boîte à côté
ok très bien voilà pour cette sortie
mesdames et messieurs sur facebook dont
violent rien entendre parler je vous le
garantis au cours des prochains jours
par ailleurs
notre
le caucus du parti québécois un petit
mot sur le registre des armes à feu
on a vu des députés dire il ya beaucoup
de nos citoyens qui nous ont dit t'as
pas une bonne idée histoire là j'ai
envie de vous poser la question
autrement que ce conte comment la pose
habituellement est ce que c'est parce un
justement enfin que sur un sujet comme
celui là il n'ya plus l'unanimité sacré
là qu'on puisse en discuter
sébastien say say say say say say say
tard sous le nom c'est parce que caucus
de députés c'est justement le choc des
idées et c'est le reflet de la société
québécoise société québécoise et les pas
monolithique et qu'elle pense pas
toujours de la même façon et dans le cas
du registre des armes à feu on voit le
québec rural mais reçue sous confronté
au québec urbaine québec urbain accepte
d'emblée le registre des armes à feu peu
avant minuit ont évidemment mais dans
québec rural
il ya les chasseurs et les
collectionneurs qui s'opposent à leur
livrant des armes à feu et c'est tout à
fait naturel que dans un caucus ces deux
visions là s'expriment ce qui est plus
dangereux c'est que si les gens sortent
du caucus divisé disent moi je vais
voter quand je vais au tpo c'est
important quand même pour avoir deux
pour caucus politique d'avoir une
certaine cohésion pour dépendre des
idées mais à l'intérieur du caucus est
tout à fait naturel qui est le choc des
idées dont le récent et alain qu'ont pu
s'opposer à ce registre sans être
accusée d'être ben dire maintenant
absolument et puis il ya vraiment une
réalité des régions est une réalité de
montréal ou des milieux urbains comme le
dit sébastien et des régions au pays où
il ya des chasseurs dans toutes les
familles et tous ces gens là ont
évidemment des armes à feu parce qu'ils
chassent pas avec un lance pierres de
toute évidence
jack layton de son vivant dans le npd
qui est plutôt qu'ils étaient surtout à
gauche sous jack layton avait eu le même
type de problème il avait certains de
ses députés ruraux surtout du nord de
l'ontario qui faisait dire à chaque fois
qu'ils retournaient dans leur compte et
je veux que vous craquiez le rejet je
veux vous voyez avec les conservateurs
là tu puisses avait fait tout un
brouhaha chez le npd demain que chez les
libéraux il y avait des députés libéraux
d'entente paul martin qui nous faisaient
quand on voit en région c'est pas des
commandites dont on passer du registre
des armes
et ça revient tout le temps c'est une
réalité qu'on y en a aussi en grande
partie mais qui est très présente en
région
alec même surpris a redit sa valeur on
va aller de l'avant avec ce projet là
mais il ya un débat d'abord ce serait
peut-être le type de projet de loi où on
pourrait permettre le vote libre par
exemple et on a environ n'a pas beaucoup
de votre libre dans nos parlements et
caractère britannique je pourrais être
intéressant que certains députés
puissent représenter effectivement les
avis de leurs concitoyens ce qui les
recueillent sur le terrain évidemment
pour l'instant le caucus du parti
québécois en discute et on a la même
position au pq on est officiellement
favorable au registre faut le dire il ya
aussi du côté des libéraux certains
députés notamment en beauce le qui se
posent des questions qui reçoivent des
commentaires de leurs citoyens qui sont
aussi peut-être existant avec ce
registre là donc c'est intéressant
qu'ils avaient une seule partie en
revanche je pense que c'est un peu aussi
où le député doit aussi que la pédagogie
dans le sens inverse expliquer à la
population pourquoi le registre
québécois il différent du registre
fédéral parce que les différents genres
différents
oui mais le projet de loi actuel qui
devant l'assemblée nationale est il
différent du registre fédéral que tu
écris parce qu'on a appris des erreurs
notamment sur la paperasse comment c'est
difficile de remplir les papiers
internet en 1995 n'est pas internet
d'aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup plus facile
maintenant et gratuit d'enregistrer des
hommes vaisselle et à l'époque du
fédéral puis l'autre demande des
récriminations les plus importantes des
chasseurs à l'époque c'était qu'on lit
traités comme des criminels en attente
parce que si on oublié d'enregistrer les
arbres qu'on ne le faisait pas on
pouvait être passé jusqu'à dix ans de
prison
c'est l'article 92 du code criminel et
ont écouté ses prêtres un peu abusif le
de nous traiter comme des criminels en
attend ce qui était effectivement très
valable or il n'y a pas ces provisions
là actuellement dans le projet de loi
déposé par le ministre moreau des
amendes salées évidemment pour inciter
les gens à enregistrer leurs rangs mais
ya pas de code criminel pas de casier
judiciaire au bout de la ligne donc des
communes des différences notables entre
les deux où on a appris à québec que ça
faut aussi que les députés l'expliqua
leurs chasseurs dans leur
circonscription retrouvent pas leur
faire les faire changer d'avis mais ça
serait déjà intéressant pour le dépôt
public de montrer les différences entre
les deux registres parlant de changement
d'avis il nous reste une minute mais
rapidement à vincent sur le
dieu qu'à montréal le mercredi derrière
lui tous les maires de la région disent
non un non retentissant à transcanada
transcanada vraiment va d'échec en échec
dans ce tout le sida oui et puis l'on se
dirige de toute évidence vers une
confrontation entre l'alberta
certainement et même une partie de
l'ouest du pays et projet montréal mais
le québec parce qu'il ya eu la sortie
aujourd'hui dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure plutôt dans l'émission du chef
du wildrose parti qui disait denis
coderre il balancé égouts d'adam dans le
fleuve
on le fait pour montrer au delà le tweet
il veut faire venir des des tankers le
pardon cherche le thème en français le
des pétroliers d'ailleurs de certains
pays et puis refuse notre pétrole alors
que le québec prend l'argent de la
péréquation
bon c'est un amalgame de tout ça on
comprendra mais c'est des gens qui sont
très fâchés qu'ils essayent fait
intéressant aujourd'hui jason kenny a
repris à peu près les mêmes arguments
dans un tweet ou si un peu plus tôt
aujourd'hui à la ronde dirige de toute
évidence dollar une confrontation un bel
arbitrage en vue pour monsieur trudeau
et ses ministres
messieurs c'est tout le temps qu'on a je
rassure les téléspectateurs et vincent
n'y a personne ici qui est considéré
comme un soldat alors on invite à
l'émission bonne bonne poursuite dans
vos chroniques et vos articles monsieur
merci merci sébastien toujours un qui
devrait lire salue le roi